ilan omar une musulmane de 37 ans n'en
est pas à sa première controverse cette
nouvelle représentante démocrate du
minnesota a choqué bien des américains
plusieurs l'accusent comme donald trump
de minimiser les attentats du 11
septembre sans people dead santé
certaines personnes affirment ilan omar
ont fait quelque chose
le 11 septembre 2001 ce quelque chose
fait référence aux pires attentats
terroristes en sol américain
dans notre chambre a répliqué dans un
tweet nous n'oublierons jamais plusieurs
l'accusent d'avoir malicieusement
utiliser les propos dylan hommage le
président affirme cette sénatrice est
candidate à l'investiture démocrate
incitent à la violence
d'autres lui reprochent d'attiser des
sentiments antimusulmans
c'est une attaque en règle affirme cet
autre sénateur démocrate contre la
représentante du minnesota il à nos
marais depuis son arrivée à washington
critiqué de toutes parts pour certains
de ses propos jugés antisémites et
maintenant ces paroles qualifié d'anti
amériques le président déclare sa porte
parole n'hésite pas à la violence mais
la dénonce
quoi qu'il en soit les menaces de mort
sont réels contre il à nos mares et la
leader démocrate nancy pelosi demandent
qu'elle soit mieux protégé les attaques
de dans notre chambre à l'endroit des
lames omar semble aussi faire partie
d'une stratégie politique
le président fait le pari qu'en dennig
une représentante musulmane il pourrait
peut-être remporter l'état du minnesota
qu'il a perdue par seulement 44 mille
voix en 2016
ici christian latreille radio-canada
washington